Last year, Kevin got his mom gloves for Christmas and a hat. And his twin sister, Karyn, what did she get their mom?
去年，凯文送给妈妈的圣诞礼物是手套和一顶帽子。而他的双胞胎妹妹凯琳，她送给妈妈的是什么呢？
I got her a pair of leather gloves, I think. Yeah. I got them before Kevin, so I was kind of angry with him, because--
我想我送的是一副皮手套。对。我比凯文先买好，所以我当时还有点生他的气，因为……
Oh, because you knew that she got leather gloves?
噢，是因为你知道她已经收到皮手套了？
No. I didn't know. So then she asked me what I was getting my mom. And then I was like, I got her gloves. And she was like, no, I got her gloves. And I'm like-- yeah. So that's why I got her the hat was because she got gloves, and then I had to go get something else.
不，我不知道。然后她问我打算送给妈妈什么。我说送的是手套。她说，不行，我已经送她手套了。我说……好吧。所以这就是我后来又买了一顶帽子的原因，因为她买了手套，我只好再去买别的东西。
Now, to be clear, he still gave her the gloves. So basically, he gave their mom the same present that Karyn gave her mom plus a hat, which might sound like he totally trumped Karyn's gift for the mom, except--
现在我们要说明的是，他最后还是把那副手套送给了她。所以基本上，他给妈妈送的礼物跟凯琳送的一模一样，只是多了一顶帽子，这听起来好像他完全压过了凯琳的礼物，除非……
I got leather gloves, though. So it's kind of different.
但我买的是皮手套。所以还是有点不同的。
Oh, yours were nicer.
噢，你的比较好。
Yeah, mine were nicer. I got leather.
对，我的比较好。我买的是真皮的。
He had to add a hat to rise to the level of her leather gloves. The French essayist Roland Barthes once wrote that when people say I love you, it usually doesn't mean the thought, I love you. And I think what he was saying was that more often when we say I love you, what we mean by it is, I need to get off the phone right now, mom. Or let's stop fighting. Or I'm not loving you right this very second, but I definitely do feel love in a more general and bigger way that I want to acknowledge with these words.
他必须加上一顶帽子才能达到她那副皮手套的水平。法国散文家罗兰·巴特曾写道，当人们说“我爱你”时，通常并不意味着字面上的“我爱你”。我想他表达的意思是，我们说“我爱你”更多时候意味着：妈，我现在得挂电话了；或者，咱们别吵了；又或者，此时此刻我虽然没感受到爱，但我内心深处确实有种更宏大、更广义的爱，我想通过这些话来表达一下。
And giving a Christmas present, I think, is a lot like that. Sometimes it means I love you, right? I want you to have this. I love you. But a hat that you get from your teenage son, it can mean all kinds of things.
我认为送圣诞礼物也差不多是这样。有时候它意味着“我爱你”，对吧？我想让你拥有这个。我爱你。但一个十几岁的儿子送的帽子，它可能包含各种各样的意义。
I bought the LEGO Star Wars Defender Class Cruiser for a little kid this year. And what I meant by it was I love you. I definitely meant I love you. But I also meant I know that your mom and dad just split up, and I feel like I should be flying out to California more often to see you. And I feel guilty about not doing that more. And I know that that is a lot of feelings to be putting on to 927 little plastic bricks. Or, you know, take the gift that Kevin got his dad last year.
今年我给一个小孩子买了乐高星球大战防卫者级巡洋舰。我表达的意思是“我爱你”。我当然是真心爱你的。但我心里也明白，你爸妈刚分开，我觉得自己应该更经常飞到加州去看看你。对于没能经常过去，我感到很愧疚。我知道，把这么多情感寄托在927块塑料积木上有点沉重。又或者，你看凯文去年送给他爸爸的礼物。
I got him some hammers because he was low on hammers. And he's good with his hands, and he likes to build stuff. So I got him some nice hammers.
我送了一些锤子给他，因为他正好缺锤子。他手艺很好，喜欢做木工，所以我给他挑了一些不错的锤子。
How'd that go over?
那他感觉怎么样？
He likes them.
他很喜欢。
I don't have to take his word for this. We're at the Arundel Mills Mall outside Baltimore, and Kevin's dad, JD, is standing right there. They're doing Christmas shopping.
我不必只听他的一面之词。我们现在在巴尔的摩郊外的阿伦德尔米尔斯购物中心，凯文的爸爸JD就在那儿。他们正在买圣诞礼物。
Do you remember the hammers?
你还记得那些锤子吗？
I do. He lost all the other ones, so his mother made him buy me hammers to replace the ones that were all gone. But they were all gone. So he brought me an assortment of hammers.
记得。他把之前的那些全弄丢了，所以他妈妈让他买锤子来替换那些不见了的。不过它们确实全丢了。所以他给我带了一套锤子。
And have you used them?
那你用过吗？
Yes, I have.
用过。
Are they nice?
它们好用吗？
They're hammers, you know.
就是些锤子，你知道的。
Not that JD is ungrateful. JD likes the hammers. JD has five kids. He loves all the presents that his kids get him, all the presents. Karyn remembers a present that she made for her dad back when she was eight or nine.
倒不是说JD不知好歹。JD挺喜欢那些锤子的。JD有五个孩子，他喜欢孩子们送他的每一份礼物，所有的礼物。凯琳还记得她八九岁时亲手为爸爸做的一份礼物。
I had these two pieces of wood. I chopped them up into little squares. They weren't really good squares. And then I painted little dots on them and made them into dice.
我有两块木头，把它们砍成小方块。做得不太工整。然后我在上面点了些点，把它们做成了骰子。
Are you sure he was disappointed in them, or did you just feel like it was a crappy present?
你确定他是失望，还是你自己觉得那是个很烂的礼物？
It was a crappy present. He couldn't just throw it away. I think that he was trying not to hurt my feelings.
那确实是个烂礼物。他当时肯定不能直接扔掉。我觉得他是在努力不伤害我的自尊心。
Well, now years have passed. She's almost twice as old. Like, do you want to say what you honestly felt about those dice?
好吧，现在几年过去了。她都快长大一倍了。你愿意说出你对那些骰子的真实感受吗？
Very unique. Very unique.
非常独特。非常独特。
Isn't it crappy, though?
难道不是很烂吗？
Oh, no. It's not. They're handmade. I'll never let go of them, OK?
噢，不。一点也不。那是手工做的，我永远不会扔掉它们，好吗？
Where are they?
它们在哪儿？
In my library in a display case.
在我的书房，放在展示柜里。
OK. This sounds like it can't possibly be true. But both kids insist that, yes, he is not being sarcastic. He saves everything, has big display cases with old presents and toys in them. But, you know, if your parents are fine with any crappy gift, that poses another problem.
好吧。这听起来完全不像是真的。但这兄妹俩坚持说，没错，他并不是在讽刺。他什么都留着，还有大型展示柜专门放旧礼物和玩具。但是，如果你的父母对任何烂礼物都无所谓，那就会带来另一个问题。
We got some stuff for our parents. My mom, she got lotion. My dad, he got some lanyard for his keys and some bottle openers.
我们给父母买了些东西。我妈妈收到了润肤露。我爸爸收到了钥匙挂绳和几个开瓶器。
Gage and William Ross are at the mall on this particular Sunday before Christmas. They're brothers, and their parents went to the casino that's part of the mall-- yes, there's a casino-- and threw them out here, Gage says, with $60 and instructions to buy them Christmas presents.
盖奇和威廉·罗斯在这个圣诞前的周日待在商场里。他们是兄弟，父母把他们扔在商场里的赌场——对，那儿有个赌场——给了他们60美元，让他们去买圣诞礼物。
We spent about $20 on their stuff, and then the rest was ours.
我们在他们礼物上花了大概20美元，剩下的钱就是我们自己的了。
Key chains.
钥匙扣。
Candy.
糖果。
Lanyard. Chewing gum.
挂绳。口香糖。
Like the twins, like a dozen other teenagers that I interviewed at the mall, they said that it is just really hard buying for your parents.
和那对双胞胎一样，就像我采访过的其他十几名在商场里的青少年一样，他们说给父母买东西真的太难了。
Because they never tell you what they really want.
因为他们从来不告诉你他们到底想要什么。
They just want you to be there and want you to be happy on Christmas morning. They really-- they don't want anything.
他们只是希望你在场，希望你在圣诞节早晨过得开心。他们真的……他们什么都不缺。
That seems kind of bad, but it's true.
这听起来有点糟糕，但确实如此。
I could take that $60 and put it in pennies, and they'd be the happiest people in the world.
我甚至把那60美元换成一美分的硬币送给他们，他们都会是世界上最幸福的人。
And then they don't care either way. You can get them anything.
而且他们什么都不挑。你可以送他们任何东西。
Anything at all.
任何东西都行。
I can get them a bag of chew toys, and they'd like it.
我可以送他们一袋狗咬胶，他们也会喜欢的。
I dare you.
我敢打赌你不敢。
It's already done.
已经送过了。
I've done it before. Her birthday, I got her a bag full of dog chew toys, yeah, and Milk Bones.
我以前干过。在她生日那天，我送了她一袋狗咬胶，还有牛奶骨饼干，真的。
And what'd she say?
她当时说什么了？
She was like, is this for the dog or for me? And I said, it's for you. And she was like, OK, thank you.
她说，这是给狗吃的还是给我的？我说，是给你的。她说，好吧，谢谢。
I could not reach his mom to get her side of the story. But I think, come on, any parent tearing off the wrapping paper and seeing that gift, like, I just think that they just think, like, huh? In this season of gift giving, if it is the thought that counts, OK, what exactly are the thoughts behind most presents?
我没法联系上他妈妈听听她的说法。但我认为，得了吧，任何父母撕开包装纸看到那份礼物时，肯定都会想：哈？在这个送礼的季节，如果心意才是最重要的，那大多数礼物背后的心意究竟是什么呢？
Well, they're complicated. Sometimes they're really, really complicated. And today on our radio show, we have stories of people giving gifts, and we have stories especially of people receiving gifts, some of these quite spectacular, and trying to divine the motives of the people who gave them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International, a special holiday show. Stay with us.
嗯，这很复杂。有时候真的、非常复杂。今天在我们的广播节目里，我们将讲述人们送礼的故事，特别是人们收到礼物的故事——有些礼物非常壮观——并试图去揣摩送礼者的动机。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行，这是一期特别的节日节目。请继续收听。
Act One, Replacement Clause. So we begin today's show about giving gifts with the gift givingest person that there is. Of course, Santa Claus is that person, a man who wants for nothing, that is, until some things change for him. Jonathan Goldstein explains.
第一幕，替代条款。所以我们以这份关于送礼的节目开始，介绍一位最擅长送礼的人。当然，那个人就是圣诞老人，一个什么都不缺的人，直到发生了一些让他改变的事情。乔纳森·戈德斯坦为您讲述。
Each life was a lonely tumble down a cold, dark chimney, falling, falling, then blackness. These were Santa's thoughts as he prepared snickerdoodles in the kitchen. In the other room, the elves performed Christmas tunes and do-si-doed.
每一段生命就像是在冰冷黑暗的烟囱里孤独地翻滚，坠落、坠落，接着是一片漆黑。这就是圣诞老人在厨房准备姜汁饼干时的想法。在另一个房间里，精灵们正在演奏圣诞歌曲，跳着方阵舞。
Carefully, he carried the tray of sweets into the living room. His wife, Martha, had been dead five years now, and he was alone, alone in a house full of elves. Jesus had dignity, apostles. All he had was high blood pressure and a communal toilet the size of a cereal bowl.
他小心翼翼地把一托盘甜点端进客厅。他的妻子玛莎已经去世五年了，他孤身一人，独自待在满是精灵的屋子里。耶稣有尊严，使徒们有尊严。他只有高血压，还有一个麦片碗大小的公用厕所。
He sat down on the couch and watched the elves dance to "Feliz Navidad." Jingles broke from the group of dancing elves and approached him. "You're killing yourself with the doodles," Jingle said, slamming down his Gin Rickey. And lately, he'd been on Santa's case to stop overeating, to get out of the house, and to get himself a girlfriend.
他坐在沙发上，看着精灵们随着《祝你圣诞快乐》跳舞。金格尔斯从跳舞的精灵群中脱身出来，走到他身边。“你吃这些饼干会害死自己的，”金格尔斯说着，重重地放下他的杜松子酒。最近，他一直盯着圣诞老人，让他别再暴饮暴食，多出门走走，给自己找个女朋友。
Glenda, the good witch of the north, lived only a few miles away and had just been left by her boyfriend, a walrus hunter who looked somewhat like a walrus himself. "Glenda's into the Wilford Brimley type," said Jingles, "so you've totally got a chance." "Glenda," said Santa, "but she's so sparkly. I miss Martha," Santa said quietly.
北方的善良女巫格琳达住得不远，刚被她的男友甩了，那人是个海象猎人，长得倒有点像海象。“格琳达喜欢威尔福德·布里姆利那种类型的，”金格尔斯说，“所以你完全有机会。”“格琳达，”圣诞老人说，“可她太闪亮了。我想念玛莎，”他轻声说道。
He knew this was true, though not the entire truth. There was missing, of course, but there was also fear. "Look, I miss Martha too," said Jingles. "But it's time to move on."
他知道这是事实，但不是全部事实。当然有思念，但也有恐惧。“看，我也想念玛莎，”金格尔斯说，“但现在是时候往前看了。”
"She was the only gal for me," said Santa. Jingles put his tiny hand on Santa's knee. "To be frank," Jingles said, "I always thought your relationship a little narcissistic. Mrs. Claus was like your twin but with bosoms. Did you plan your outfits together?"
“她是我的唯一，”圣诞老人说。金格尔斯把小手放在圣诞老人的膝盖上。“坦白说，”金格尔斯说，“我一直觉得你们的关系有点自恋。圣诞夫人简直就是你的双胞胎，只是多了对胸部。你们是不是连穿搭都是一起策划的？”
"We just had the same taste," Santa sobbed. "Jingle Bell Rock" started up on the squeeze box, and Santa took that as his cue to head to bed. He never could stand rock and roll Christmas songs.
“我们只是品味相同，”圣诞老人啜泣着。手风琴开始演奏《铃儿响叮当摇滚乐》，圣诞老人以此为信号准备去睡觉。他从来受不了摇滚风格的圣诞歌曲。
He liked Christmas songs, and he liked rock and roll. He just didn't like them together. Martha had felt the exact same way. On their first year anniversary, Martha presented him with a pen, the fancy kind that came in a box.
他喜欢圣诞歌曲，也喜欢摇滚乐。他只是不喜欢把它们合在一起。玛莎也有同样的感觉。在他们结婚一周年纪念日那天，玛莎送了他一支笔，就是那种装在盒子里的高级货。
"Oh, for the love of Saint Nicholas," Santa had said, "what good is a pen? I'll just end up losing it. Save your money and buy yourself something nice, or let me buy for you. That would make me most happy of all."
“噢，看在圣尼古拉斯的份上，”圣诞老人当时说，“一支笔有什么用？我最后肯定会弄丢的。省下钱给你自己买点好的，或者让我给你买礼物。那才是我最开心的。”
For a man famous for his giving, Santa was terrible at receiving. Martha took the pen back and apologized. And that was the end of the gifts.
作为一个以送礼闻名的人，圣诞老人极其不擅长收礼。玛莎收回了笔，并表示歉意。从此以后，他们就不再互送礼物了。
After she had died and Santa was cleaning out her stuff, in a jewelry box filled with the old love letters he'd sent during their courtship, he found the pen. He clutched it on the edge of the bed and wept. Jingles took it upon himself to just go ahead and arrange a date for Santa unbidden.
在她去世后，圣诞老人整理她的遗物时，在一个装满了他恋爱期间写给她的旧情书的珠宝盒里，他发现了那支笔。他紧紧攥着笔，坐在床沿上哭泣。金格尔斯自作主张，执意要为圣诞老人安排一次约会。
"Glenda's expecting you at eight," said Jingles, sidling up to him in the reindeer stable one morning. "And do me a favor. Trim your whiskers and put on your spanx." As instructed, Santa appeared at Glenda's doorstep that evening, a paper bag of roasted chestnuts in his hand.
“格琳达在八点等你，”一天早上，金格尔斯在驯鹿棚悄悄靠近他说，“帮我个忙，修修你的胡子，穿上束身衣。”按照指示，当晚圣诞老人出现在格琳达的家门口，手里拎着一纸袋烤栗子。
"Come on in, Mr. Claus," said Glenda with a sweep of her arm. She was dressed all in white, and the house smelled of fresh gingerbread. Santa observed with a smile that there were several magic wands, gold and sparkly, in the umbrella rack.
“快进来，克劳斯先生，”格琳达挥着手臂说道。她全身穿着白衣，屋子里弥漫着新鲜姜饼的味道。圣诞老人微笑着发现伞架里放着几根魔法棒，金光闪闪的。
For most of the evening they sat by the hearth and made clumsy conversation about the loneliness of living at the North Pole, mostly. "Unless I absolutely have to, I don't even bother going outside," said Glenda. "And when the cable goes out, it is out," said Santa.
大半个晚上他们都坐在壁炉旁，大多在进行着笨拙的对话，谈论住在北极的孤独感。“除非必须去，否则我根本不出门，”格琳达说。“有线电视坏了的时候，那就真的坏了，”圣诞老人说。
After a beat of silence, Glenda looked at him, a smile across her face. "Is this a good conversation?" she asked. Santa laughed and assured her it was.
沉默片刻后，格琳达看着他，脸上露出了笑容。“这是一次愉快的交谈吗？”她问。圣诞老人大笑着向她保证是的。
They played cribbage, drank eggnog, and watched the snow outside the window fall. And in the vestibule, before leaving, Glenda placed her hand on Santa's shoulder and kissed him right beneath his eye. As she did, Santa felt as though his chest were a chimney, and inside a sleeping dove was stirring awake.
他们玩了纸牌游戏，喝了蛋酒，看着窗外的雪花飘落。在临走前的门厅里，格琳达把手放在圣诞老人的肩膀上，吻了他的眼下。那一刻，圣诞老人感觉自己的胸口就像一个烟囱，里面有一只沉睡的鸽子被惊醒了。
They made a date for the following weekend. And just before he left, Glenda gave him a container of cranberry mini muffins she'd baked. Santa told her he could not accept such a gift, at which point she thrust it into this chest with surprising force. "Take it," she said. On the sleigh ride home, Santa realized with mixed feelings that he'd hardly thought of Martha the whole night.
他们约好下周末再见。就在他离开前，格琳达给了他一盒她烤的小蔓越莓松饼。圣诞老人说他不能接受这份礼物，这时她出人意料地用力将盒子塞进他的怀里。“拿着，”她说。在回程的雪橇上，圣诞老人带着复杂的心情意识到，这一整晚他几乎没怎么想起玛莎。
When he showed up the following Saturday, Glenda was all apologies. "Change of plans," she said, stopping him in the vestibule. "Sheila's here, flew in this afternoon from Tampa."
当他下周六出现时，格琳达满是歉意。“计划变了，”她在门厅拦住他说，“希拉在这儿，今天下午从坦帕飞过来的。”
"Sheila?" asked Santa. "AKA, the wicked witch of the east," she said quickly, "My old college roommate." "College?" asked Santa. "For witches?"
“希拉？”圣诞老人问。“也就是东方的邪恶女巫，”她飞快地说，“我以前的大学室友。”“大学？”圣诞老人问，“女巫上的大学？”
"She's always showing up like this," Glenda went on. "Every time there's trouble in Tampa, I get a knock at the door." In the den, Sheila was lying on the couch in a kittenish tangle, all in black and smoking what smelled like European cigarettes.
“她总是这样不请自来，”格琳达继续说道，“每次坦帕出点事，我就得听到敲门声。”在书房里，希拉正蜷在沙发上，全身黑衣，抽着闻起来像欧洲香烟的东西。
She studied Santa while playing with her hair. "Hey, chubs," she said. "I told you to smoke outside," said Glenda with exasperation. She went into the kitchen to get some fruitcake as Santa made his way over to the couch.
她一边摆弄头发一边打量圣诞老人。“嘿，胖子，”她说。“我告诉过你要去外面抽，”格琳达懊恼地说。她走进厨房去拿水果蛋糕，而圣诞老人朝沙发走去。
Sheila didn't move. So he squeezed into the corner, her black stocking toes touching his thigh. "So what do you do, fatso?" Santa began to stammer. "Oh, I--"
希拉一动不动。于是他挤进角落里，她穿着黑色丝袜的脚尖碰到了他的大腿。“那你平时都做什么，胖子？”圣诞老人开始结巴。“噢，我……”
"Relax, [BLEEP]. I know you are. You're famous," she said, taking the last cookie from the serving tray. "So how do you know Glenda?"
“放松点，[消音]。我知道你是谁。你很出名，”她说，从托盘里拿走了最后一块饼干，“那你怎么认识格琳达的？”
"Oh, we're neighbors," said Santa. "And you buy this good witch [BLEEP]?" she asked in a whisper. "A downward turn in the black arts, and all of a sudden she's moved to the North Pole and rebranded herself a good witch. Whoever heard of a good witch, am I right? It's an oxymoron, like baby grand or jolly fat man. Everyone knows fat men are sad. Look at you, totally depressed. Am I right?"
“噢，我们是邻居，”圣诞老人说。“你也信这个善良女巫的[消音]话？”她低声问道，“黑魔法没落了，她突然搬到北极，重新包装自己成了善良女巫。谁听说过善良女巫？我有说错吗？这本身就是矛盾语，就像‘袖珍三角钢琴’或‘快乐的胖子’一样。大家都知道胖男人是悲伤的。看看你，完全一副抑郁的样子。我没说错吧？”
"I mean, maybe a little," Santa said. "My wife recently died." "And what's with this Glenda [BLEEP]?" interrupted Sheila. "Her name's Linda."
“我是说，也许有一点，”圣诞老人说。“我妻子刚去世不久。”“那这个格琳达[消音]是怎么回事？”希拉打断道，“她叫琳达。”
Often, when Santa didn't know what else to say, he'd break into a jolly sounding chuckle. He tried it just then, but the chuckle got caught in his throat and came out sounding sweaty and choked. Sheila stared at him.
通常，当圣诞老人不知道该说什么时，他会发出一种欢快的笑声。他刚才试着笑了一下，但笑声卡在喉咙里，听起来既紧张又窒息。希拉盯着他。
"You have this weird crap in your beard," she said. She reached in to pull it out, and as she did, she brought her face in close enough for Santa to smell her. Whereas Glenda smelled like baby powder and cinnamon, Sheila smelled of something he couldn't quite put his finger on. Cigarettes, of course, but something else, too. It set the chimney in his chest ablaze, ashy black doves trying to flap out their flaming wings.
“你胡子里有奇怪的东西，”她说。她伸手去清理，动作间把脸凑得很近，让圣诞老人闻到了她身上的味道。格琳达闻起来像爽身粉和肉桂，而希拉闻起来有一种他无法确切形容的味道。当然有香烟味，但还有别的。这让胸口的烟囱烧了起来，灰黑色的鸽子拼命扑动着着火的翅膀想冲出来。
As Sheila rummaged through his beard, the look on her face was all little girl concentration. "You have nice bone structure," she said. "You should try wearing black. It would have a slimming effect."
当希拉翻找他的胡子时，她脸上的表情充满了像小女孩一样的专注。“你的骨骼结构不错，”她说，“你应该试着穿黑色。会有显瘦的效果。”
Withdrawing a tiny shriveled raisin from Santa's beard, Sheila crinkled up her face and flicked it on the carpet. "Eww, gross," she said. Glenda walked back into the room with drinks. And when Santa reached for one, he realized his hand was shaking.
从圣诞老人的胡子里扯出一颗皱巴巴的葡萄干后，希拉皱起脸把它弹到地毯上。“呃，真恶心，”她说。格琳达端着饮料走回房间。当圣诞老人伸手去拿时，他意识到自己的手在发抖。
He excused himself to use the bathroom, where he thought he might hum a few carols to calm himself down. Everything inside the bathroom was glittery and white, white glittery soaps, shampoos, curtains. But there, hanging from the white shower curtain rod, was something black.
他借故去洗手间，想哼几首颂歌来让自己冷静一下。洗手间里一切都是闪闪发光的白色：白色的闪光肥皂、洗发水、窗帘。但在白色的浴帘杆上，挂着黑色的东西。
Strung there for all the world to see were a pair of silky black stockings, Sheila's black stockings. For years, Santa had dealt intimately with stockings, stuffing them with coal or presents, and never thought about it twice. But just then, seeing those black stockings of hers, being alone with them, something came over him. And suddenly, he was on his toes biting the tips like a playful pup, like a fat old playful pup.
在那里，向全世界展示着一双丝绸黑丝袜，希拉的黑丝袜。多年来，圣诞老人一直与袜子打交道，往里塞煤块或礼物，从未多想过一次。但就在那一刻，看着她的黑丝袜，独自面对它们，某种情绪席卷了他。突然间，他踮起脚尖，像只顽皮的小狗一样咬着袜尖，像只年老而顽皮的胖狗。
Returning to the living room, Santa sat back down on the couch and listened, enraptured, as Sheila encouraged him to revise his policy on naughtiness. Santa nodded his head as though giving her suggestion some thought. In bed that night, Santa replayed each of Sheila's words and gestures.
回到客厅，圣诞老人重新坐回沙发上，听着希拉鼓励他修改关于“调皮”的政策，听得如痴如醉。圣诞老人点着头，好像在认真考虑她的建议。那天晚上在床上，圣诞老人反复回味希拉说的每一句话和每一个动作。
Sheila said whatever she felt like, touching and smelling everything like an animal. She was not afraid to take, avail herself of the world, drinks, cigarettes, hospitality. Without so much as asking, she'd even plunged her hand into Santa's Shirley Temple, plucking the maraschino cherry right out and using his hat to wipe her hands.
希拉想说什么就说什么，像动物一样触摸和闻嗅一切。她不害怕索取，享受世界，饮料、香烟、好客。甚至连问都不问，她就直接把手插进圣诞老人的雪利小神童饮料里，捏出那颗红樱桃，然后用他的帽子擦手。
For Santa, one so in love with giving, he could not help but see before him a kind of black hole, a sexy and sublime black hole into which he could deliver forth his greatest gift. In Sheila, he saw an insatiable hunger for life. With such a woman to give to, to give himself to, it would feel as though every day was Christmas.
对于圣诞老人这样一个热爱给予的人来说，他忍不住看到眼前有一个黑洞，一个性感而崇高的黑洞，他可以把自己最伟大的礼物送进去。在希拉身上，他看到了对生活永不满足的渴望。有这样一个女人可以给予，可以把自己给予她，那感觉就像每天都是圣诞节一样。
When they had made plans for the following weekend, Glenda had asked if Santa could bring along a friend for Sheila. And so he showed up with Jingles. Anything to help a brother out, Jingles had said. Strolling into Glenda's living room, Jingles did that thing where he jumped onto the couch while crossing his legs in midair. He landed right beside Sheila.
当他们为下一个周末做计划时，格琳达问圣诞老人能不能带个朋友给希拉。于是他带上了金格尔斯。金格尔斯说，为了兄弟，义不容辞。走进格琳达的客厅，金格尔斯做了他那套动作：跳上沙发，在半空中交叉双腿，稳稳地落在希拉身边。
"You are just too cute for words," exclaimed Sheila. "Try anyway," said Jingles, snipping the tip of his cigar. It was the length of his forearm.
“你可爱得没法用语言形容了，”希拉惊叹道。“试着形容一下，”金格尔斯说，剪掉了他雪茄的头，那雪茄有他的前臂那么长。
"I'd prefer to keep the house smoke free," said Glenda. "More like fun free," said Sheila. "Say, what do you call people who live around here anyway? North Pollack's?"
“我希望屋子里不要有烟味，”格琳达说。“不如说是‘不准享乐’吧，”希拉说，“对了，你们把住在这一带的人叫什么？‘北极波兰人’？”
"We call ourselves Cold Poles," said Jingles. "Ever put your tongue on a cold pole, honey? Tends to get stuck there." Sheila slapped him on the head. "Dork," she said, laughing.
“我们叫自己‘冷极人’，”金格尔斯说，“亲爱的，有没有试过把舌头贴在冷的电线杆上？很容易粘住的。”希拉拍了拍他的头。“笨蛋，”她笑着说。
Sheila and Jingles had a million things to talk about. All the while, Glenda and Santa just sort of sat there smiling awkwardly and watching the snowfall. "It's an uninhabitable wasteland," Santa heard Sheila say. "Tampa sounds awesome," said Jingles. "If only I could convince El Jefe over there to move the operation south."
希拉和金格尔斯有无数的话题可聊。而格琳达和圣诞老人就那样尴尬地坐着微笑，看着窗外的雪景。“这是一个荒无人烟的荒地，”圣诞老人听到希拉说。“坦帕听起来棒极了，”金格尔斯说，“要是能说服那边的‘头儿’把基地搬到南方就好了。”
Jingles looked over at Santa, and seeing his bro struggling with his date decided to kick things into gear. "Come on y'all," said the elf, addressing the group. "Gather around for a little spin o' the bottle."
金格尔斯看了看圣诞老人，看到兄弟在约会中陷入挣扎，决定加把劲。“来吧各位，”精灵对着大家说，“都聚过来，咱们玩转瓶子游戏。”
"I've got just the one," said Sheila, downing the last of the red wine straight from the bottle. "Spin the what?" asked Glenda. Sheila rolled her eyes, placed the bottle down on the carpet, and spun.
“我正好有一个，”希拉说着，直接对着瓶子喝干了最后一点红酒。“转什么？”格琳达问。希拉翻了个白眼，把瓶子放在地毯上，转动起来。
Santa watched the bottle spin with an anxiety that bordered on mania. What if the bottle dictated that he was to kiss Sheila? He would almost certainly die.
圣诞老人看着旋转的瓶子，焦虑近乎疯狂。如果瓶子指向他，要他吻希拉怎么办？他一定会死掉的。
But he did not have to ponder such a kiss for very long, for soon the bottle slowed to a halt, pointing directly at Jingles. And when Sheila licked her lips and leaned her face downward, Jingles grabbed her head in his small hands and planted his tiny mouth on hers. Santa felt the chimney fire in his chest snuff out.
但他没时间考虑那种吻，因为很快瓶子就慢了下来，正好指向金格尔斯。当希拉舔了舔嘴唇，俯下脸时，金格尔斯用小手抓住她的头，把他的小嘴印在她的嘴唇上。圣诞老人感到胸口的烟囱火瞬间熄灭了。
He and Glenda watched them kiss. Then after a while they watched the snowfall. Then they went back to watching them kiss. Eventually Jingles led Sheila into the vestibule where he said he wanted to show her the secret to getting the tips of his shoes so curly.
他和格琳达看着他们接吻。过了一会儿，他们又看向窗外的雪景。然后又回到看他们接吻。最终，金格尔斯把希拉带到门厅，说要向她展示如何让鞋尖变卷的秘密。
Left alone, and at somewhat of a loss, Glenda got up and fished around in a cabinet drawer beside the couch. Santa thought she might be looking for a game of some sort. But then she said," "I have something for you."
剩下一个人，不知所措的格琳达站起身，在沙发旁的抽屉里翻找。圣诞老人以为她在找什么游戏。但随后她说：“我有东西要给你。”
She held out a glistening package. "No way, Jose," Santa said. "I'm the gift giver around here. And it's not even Christmas yet."
她拿出一个闪闪发光的包装。“千万别，何塞（伙计），”圣诞老人说，“我是这里的送礼人。而且现在离圣诞节还有好几天呢。”
Santa was about to really kick up a fuss. But then, as a downright witchy look fell across Glenda' face, he trailed off. "It's nothing that big," she insisted, thrusting the present at his chest. "Besides, it was fun trying to find the perfect something for you. And then to actually find it, there's no greater feeling in the world. But look who I'm telling this to."
圣诞老人正想发作，但当格琳达脸上露出一种极其狡黠的表情时，他闭嘴了。“也不是什么大东西，”她坚持着，把礼物塞进他怀里，“再说，寻找最适合你的礼物太有趣了。而最后真正找到了，那是世界上最伟大的感觉。但我这是跟谁说呢。”
Hearing her words and seeing the look of excitement on her face, Santa had a puzzling thought. Perhaps he'd somehow misjudged things. Perhaps he'd somehow gotten it wrong.
听到她的话，看到她脸上兴奋的神情，圣诞老人心中闪过一个困惑的念头。也许他一直以来都误判了形势。也许他一直以来都搞错了。
By refusing the gifts people wished to bestow on him, he'd consistently failed to give the experience of giving. He'd hogged that particular pleasure all to himself. And so he took the package. It was flat and square.
通过拒绝人们想要给他的礼物，他一贯地未能给予他人“给予”的体验。他把那种独特的快乐全部独占了。于是，他接过了包裹。它是扁平的方形。
Tearing the wrapping paper open, he saw it was a record, Rocking Christmas Party Songs, Volume One. He absolutely hated it. Not just because the thought of listening to it made him feel like one of those old white haired hippies who had to make everything, from getting their prostate checked to celebrating Christmas, not just a good time but a rocking good time. But it was also one of those gifts that said something about the recipient, something that was hard to swallow, like the gift of a back scratcher that says you're alone in this world and must fend for yourself or the gift of a warm house coat that says your days of party dresses are over.
撕开包装纸，他看到那是一张唱片，《摇滚圣诞派对歌曲，第一卷》。他简直厌恶透了。不仅是因为想到要听它，就让他觉得自己像那些头发花白的老嬉皮士，什么都要做，从检查前列腺到庆祝圣诞，不仅要开心，还要摇滚到爆。而且这种礼物代表了对收礼者的某种评价，很难接受，就像送一个背部抓痒耙是在说“你在这个世界上是孤独的，必须自力更生”，或者送一件厚睡袍是在说“你的派对舞裙生涯已经结束了”。
The gift of a perfectly awful Christmas album being handed to you by a woman who liked you said loud and clear, you must learn to compromise. For after all his years of giving, Santa knew better than anyone that we don't always receive what we want nor even what we deserve. We receive what life brings us. And when it comes to life, we haven't a choice but to open our arms.
当一个喜欢你的女人递给你一张烂透了的圣诞专辑，其含义响亮而清晰：你必须学会妥协。因为在做了这么多年的送礼者之后，圣诞老人比任何人都清楚，我们并不总是能收到我们想要的，甚至是不一定能收到我们应得的。我们收到的是生活带给我们的一切。而面对生活，我们除了敞开双臂拥抱，别无选择。
"I love it," said Santa with a half smile. Unpeeling the plastic, they placed the album on the record player. Santa held out his arms, and Glenda entered his embrace. And together, they danced about the room as Chuck Berry belted out "Run Rudolph Run." And it was almost enough to drown out the sounds in the vestibule.
“我爱死它了，”圣诞老人半笑着说。撕开塑封，他们把专辑放上唱片机。圣诞老人张开双臂，格琳达投入他的怀抱。他们一起在房间里跳着舞，查克·贝里高唱着《鲁道夫快跑》。那声音大得足以淹没门厅里的响动。
[MUSIC - CHUCK BERRY, "RUN, RUDOLPH, RUN"]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里，《鲁道夫快跑》]
So do you know what you're getting your parents for Christmas?
那么，你知道给父母买什么圣诞礼物了吗？
Not yet. I've never been good at this kind of thing. As I'm getting older, it's like I'm supposed to have some money so I can actually buy them a nice enough gift where it's not just, you know.
还没有。我从来不擅长这种事。随着我年龄增长，好像我应该赚点钱，这样就能给他们买一份像样的礼物，而不是那种，你懂的。
Do you remember what you got them last year?
你还记得去年给他们买了什么吗？
I believe I got my dad a Sons of Anarchy t-shirt.
我记得给爸爸买了一件《混乱之子》的T恤。
This is Larry Daniels, 19 years old, goes to community college, doesn't have a job. He got his mom Cowboys memorabilia last year.
这是拉里·丹尼尔斯，19岁，在社区学院上学，没有工作。去年他给妈妈买了牛仔队的纪念品。
I believe it was lounging pants.
我想是休闲裤。
That's like sweatpants?
那种运动裤吗？
Yes, kind of. They're like sweatpants, only made of a thinner material, I believe.
对，差不多。就是那种运动裤，只是材质更薄，我想。
And you've seen her in them?
你看见她穿过吗？
Yes, I have. She loves to lounge.
看见过。她很喜欢休闲。
Did you see him in the Sons of Anarchy t-shirt?
你看见过他穿那件《混乱之子》T恤吗？
I don't believe I've ever seen him wear it. But he may have worn it-- as I'm getting older, I'm starting to realize my memory's fading as it goes on. But they were generally happy with the present that I got them because-- yep.
我不记得见过他穿过。但他可能穿过……随着年龄增长，我开始意识到我的记忆力正在衰退。但他们通常对我买的礼物很满意，因为——是的。
You have no idea what you're going to get them at all.
你根本不知道到底要给他们买什么。
No, I do not. I feel like I may never find something in time, you know? I'm just so lost.
不，我不知道。我觉得我可能永远没法及时找到礼物，你知道吗？我太迷茫了。
Could you just ask them what they want?
你可以直接问他们想要什么吗？
I could.
我可以。
But it sounds like-- it's funny talking to you. It sounds like it's never occurred to you just to ask them.
但听起来……跟你说话很有意思。听起来你从来没想过直接问他们。
That's true. I'm not a question asking person. I'm just usually-- I get nervous.
那倒是。我不属于那种会问问题的人。我通常只是……我会紧张。
So you've never asked them, what do you want for Christmas?
所以你从来没问过他们：“圣诞节想要什么？”
No, I don't think I have. I don't know. It just feels like if ask them, they'll tell me. And, like, OK, they'll expect to get it, you know?
没有，我不记得我问过。我不知道。只是觉得如果我问了，他们就会告诉我。然后，好吧，他们就会期待收到它，你知道吗？
Because a lot of times when you watch, like, TV shows or movies where a kid-- their birthday is coming up. And they're like, oh, I want this. I want this. I'm probably going to get it, because I've said I want this.
因为很多时候当你像看电视节目或电影里，孩子——他们的生日快到了。他们会说，哦，我想要这个。我想要那个。我可能会买到它，因为我已经说过了我想要这个。
But then they don't get it. They're disappointed. I'm, like, OK, maybe they'll be the same way. But I don't know.
但如果最后没买到，他们会失望的。我在想，好吧，也许他们也会一样。但我不知道。
But wait. But you could get them what they want.
但是等等，你可以买他们想要的东西啊。
I could. Yes, I could. Actually, yeah, I probably could. Maybe. Yeah, maybe.
我可以。是的，我可以。其实，是的，我可能确实能买到。也许吧。是的，也许。
Do you think that they would ask you for something that you wouldn't be able to get them?
你觉得他们会要求你买一些你买不起的东西吗？
I don't know. They might, actually. But I've never been in that situation. Or I may have been. Maybe once or twice I've been in that situation, and I got them something else, like, say, a mug, like a coffee mug or one of those kind of mugs that you see in a bar almost, only plastic, like a freezable mug, I guess.
我不知道。他们可能会的。但我从没遇到过那种情况。或者我可能遇到过。也许有一两次遇到过那种情况，我就买了别的代替，比如，一个杯子，那种咖啡杯，或者你在酒吧里能看到的那种，只是塑料做的，比如那种可以冷冻的杯子，我想。
You mean like a mug for beer?
你是说像啤酒杯那样的？
Yes.
是的。
So wait. So this is a present you actually got them.
等等，所以这是你真正买给他们的礼物。
Yes, I did get my mom a mug one year.
是的，我有一年确实给我妈买了个杯子。
How'd that go?
结果如何？
She loved it. I mean, I just thought, this is cool. I'll get her this, you know? That's usually what I do when I see a present. I'm like, this is cool. I'll get them this. That's kind of how I go through things, you know?
她很喜欢。我是说，我只是觉得，这很酷。我就买这个给她，你知道吗？我看到礼物时通常就是这么做的。我会想，这很酷，我就给他们买这个。我做事大概就是这种逻辑，你懂的。
So you're here at the mall. You're going to wander around until something hits you?
所以你来到商场。你打算到处逛逛，直到什么东西吸引你？
Yes. It's worked well so far. Usually. But hopefully it'll work this time again.
是的。目前为止效果还不错。通常是这样。但希望这次也能管用。
Coming up, over 600 boxes, gifts from decades ago opened one by one. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后，超过600个盒子，几十年前的礼物被一一打开。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题。
Today's show, "The Thought That Counts." For this holiday season, we have stories of gifts and what people intend when they send them, which can be very, very complicated. We have arrived at Act Two of our program.
今天的节目是“心意最重要”。在这个节日季，我们要讲一些关于礼物的故事，以及人们寄送礼物时的真实意图，这可能会非常、非常复杂。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Your Junk in a Box. So people, of course, are opening up packages full of treasures all year round, not just at Christmas. And, you know, when it's not members of your family or your friends or anybody who you've ever met who packed the boxes, it can be confusing. Starlee Kine has this story.
第二幕，你盒子里的垃圾。所以，人们当然是一年四季都在打开装满宝藏的包裹，不仅仅是在圣诞节。而且，你知道，当包裹不是你的家人或朋友，或者任何你见过的人打包的，这可能会让人困惑。斯塔利·凯恩有这个故事。
When I was in fifth grade, my class buried a time capsule in the grass that jutted against the school parking lot. We didn't feel like being generous with our gift giving towards future generations. Why should they get our best toys?
我在五年级的时候，我们班在学校停车场边上的草地里埋了一个时间胶囊。我们当时并不想对未来几代人表现得太慷慨。他们凭什么得到我们最好的玩具？
So we only tossed in the Garbage Pail Kid cards that we had doubles of, or jelly bracelets, a 10-year-old's most disposable possession. I can picture the people who will one day stumble upon our capsule. They'll turn our junk over in their hands. It'll be easy to figure out it was buried by children in a spot where there once was a school. But why we chose this crap, what we could have possibly meant by it, that will be the stumper.
所以我们只扔进去了一些多余的“垃圾桶小孩”卡片，或者果冻手环，一个10岁孩子最廉价的财产。我可以想象未来某一天偶然发现我们胶囊的人。他们会拿着我们的垃圾翻来覆去地看。很容易就能看出这是孩子们埋在这里的，这里曾经有一所学校。但为什么我们要选这些破烂，我们当时心里到底想什么，那才是一个真正的难点。
In a museum in Pittsburgh, there's a group of people who spend their days opening time capsules and trying to piece together the original thinking behind each one. These time capsules were all left by one person, Andy Warhol. There are 621 of them.
在匹兹堡的一家博物馆里，有一群人整天都在打开时间胶囊，试图拼凑出每一个胶囊背后的原始构想。这些时间胶囊都是由一个人留下的：安迪·沃霍尔。共有621个。
He didn't bury them, and they weren't capsule shaped. There were just cardboard boxes filled with his stuff. And what makes them so different than the regular archives left behind by famous artists when they die-- because he also has those-- were that these time capsules, and he did call them time capsules, were deemed one big piece of art.
他并没有埋藏它们，它们也不是胶囊形状的。它们只是装满他东西的硬纸盒。使它们与著名艺术家去世后留下的常规档案——因为他也有那些——如此不同的原因在于，这些时间胶囊，而且他确实称它们为时间胶囊，被视为一件完整的艺术品。
All 621 go together as a set. The contents have to stay together, too. Warhol started the project in 1974. He'd fill boxes up with various objects. Each one is packed to the brim, and they take longer to open and go through than you may think.
所有621个作为一个整体存在。内容物也必须保持在一起。沃霍尔在1974年开始了这项工程。他把各种各样的物品装满盒子。每一个都装得满满当当，打开并检查它们所花的时间比你想象的要长。
The first capsule was opened in 1991. And two decades later, there are still ones that haven't been gotten to yet. The day I visit, the museum has three full-time cataloguers whose jobs are just to open and sort through the boxes, five days a week, eight hours a day, Elaina, Erin, and Marie.
第一个胶囊在1991年被打开。二十年后的今天，还有一些没被触及过。我参观的那天，博物馆有三位全职编目员，她们的工作就是打开并整理这些盒子，每周五天，每天八小时，分别是埃莱娜、艾琳和玛丽。
All three look like they stepped out of a '40s screwball comedy, pencil skirts, black glasses, soft curls. When I arrive, they just opened a new capsule. There's this long conference room table completely covered with the items they found inside.
三个人看起来都像是从40年代的疯狂喜剧里走出来的：铅笔裙、黑框眼镜、柔和的卷发。我到达时，她们刚打开一个新的胶囊。长长的会议桌上完全铺满了她们在里面发现的物品。
We have some items signed by Nick Rhodes, Duran Duran lead singer? Guitarist? Somebody in Duran Duran.
我们有一些由尼克·罗兹签名的物品，杜兰杜兰乐队的主唱？吉他手？杜兰杜兰里的某个人。
Letters from Liza Minnelli. There's also her wedding invitation. There's an invitation to President Reagan's inauguration, which is next to an ashtray that has some Keith Haring artwork, I believe, on it.
莉莎·明内利的信。还有她的婚礼请柬。还有一张里根总统就职典礼的邀请函，旁边是一个印有凯斯·哈林艺术作品的烟灰缸。
There's a Christmas card from John Waters with a dollar bill in it. There's a note from Bianca Jagger signed with a lipstick kiss. It's so close to what I would imagine Andy Warhol's house being filled with that it feels set up.
还有一张约翰·沃特斯的圣诞贺卡，里面夹着一张一美元的钞票。还有一张比安卡·贾格尔留下的便条，上面盖着一个口红印。这里太像我想象中安迪·沃霍尔家里的样子了，感觉像是摆拍的。
It's as though his friends just walked from room to room drawing on or pressing their lips against anything that was the least bit ordinary. There's also two small drawings by Basquiat just lying there on the table with everything else. One is a portrait he did of Andy while he slept.
好像他的朋友们只是从一个房间走到另一个房间，在任何平凡的东西上涂鸦或印上他们的嘴唇。桌上还有两幅巴斯奎特的小画，和其他东西混在一起。其中一幅是他画的安迪睡觉时的肖像。
The girls say that this just happened sometimes. All of a sudden they'll stumble upon some priceless art that has never been seen or pieces of Warhol's that were believed to have been lost forever. And then there are the wild cards. This is the museum's director, Eric Shiner.
女孩们说这种情况偶尔会发生。突然之间，她们会偶然发现一些从未见过的无价艺术品，或者被认为永远丢失的沃霍尔作品。然后还有一些“万能牌”。这是博物馆馆长埃里克·谢纳。
Did you see this yet?
你看过这个吗？
No, what is it?
没有，是什么？
I believe that would be Rob Lowe, naked, wrapped in a huge stuffed animal snake. Is there anything on the back?
我想那是罗伯·洛，裸体，裹着一条巨大的毛绒蛇。背面有什么东西吗？
Yeah, there's a note.
是的，有个便条。
Let's see. Oh, it's actually signed Rob Lowe. "Andy, thanks so much for all the fun. Don't forget I would love something from you. This is a trade. Thanks again. Call me in LA," with Rob Lowe's phone number. And he's sending this photograph in hopes of getting something from Warhol as a gift in exchange.
让我们看看。噢，实际上是罗伯·洛签名的。“安迪，非常感谢你带来的所有乐趣。别忘了，我很想要你的一件作品。这是一次交换。再次感谢。给我打洛杉矶的电话，”后面还有罗伯·洛的电话号码。他送这张照片是希望能从沃霍尔那里换回一件艺术品作为礼物。
I can't put into words how badly I wanted that Rob Lowe photo. The degree of willpower it took to not slowly, over the course of the afternoon, slide it more and more off the table until it fell to the ground, where I would then stand on it until I was able to drop something else, something less valuable-- my scarf, the microphone-- so as to then be able to stoop down and transfer the photo from the floor to my bag. It wasn't because it seemed worth a lot of money.
我无法用言语表达我有多么想要那张罗伯·洛的照片。我花了一下午的时间，凭借多大的意志力才克制住自己，没有让它慢慢滑到桌边直到掉在地上，然后踩在上面，再扔下别的东西——我的围巾、麦克风——好让自己能够蹲下去，把照片从地板转到我的包里。这并不是因为它看起来价值连城。
I wanted it for, like, my house, to hang on my fridge. I couldn't understand how we weren't calling the number. When you come across a wallet-size photo of a naked Rob Lowe wrapped in a giant toy snake, which you can tell was done in complete sincerity because of the look on his face, a look that no one but me and the other people in this room would ever see, you do as the photo says and call the number.
我想要它，像放在家里贴在冰箱上。我不明白为什么我们不打那个电话。当你偶然发现一张罗伯·洛裹着巨大的玩具蛇的钱包照片，你可以看出这是绝对真诚的，因为他脸上的表情——那种除了我和房间里其他人之外永远不会有人看到的表情——你就该照着照片上说的去做，拨打那个号码。
I had questions that needed answering, such as, did he take the photo himself with a timer, or did he have a friend do it? But like everything else, the photo was just put down on the table. And once it was catalogued, back into the box it would go.
我有很多问题需要回答，比如，是他自己用定时器拍的，还是让朋友拍的？但就像其他所有东西一样，照片只是被放在桌子上。一旦编目完成，它就会被放回盒子里。
Andy Warhol was a major hoarder, known for it. For every original Keith Haring or Basquiat or Rob Lowe, the girls will find piles and piles of junk mail. There was a box full of Eddie Bauer catalogs. And they found actual garbage, like finger nail clippings and rotten sandwiches.
安迪·沃霍尔是个大囤积狂，众所周知。对于每一件原创的凯斯·哈林或巴斯奎特或罗伯·洛作品，女孩们都会发现一堆又一堆的垃圾邮件。有一个装满艾迪·鲍尔目录的盒子。她们还发现了真正的垃圾，比如指甲屑和腐烂的三明治。
I found some hair and underpants.
我发现了一些头发和内裤。
Whose?
谁的？
I don't know. But they were dirty. They were horrible, yeah. They were, like, Jockey small briefs.
我不知道。但它们很脏。它们很恐怖，是的。大概是像Jockey牌的小内裤。
How do you know they were dirty?
你怎么知道它们很脏？
It was visible.
显而易见。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They were stained.
上面有污渍。
All of this makes more sense because of how the boxes started. The story goes that in 1974 Warhol was moving his studio from one building in New York to another. The problem was he was notoriously tight with his money, loved buying stuff, hated paying people. And so he didn't hire a moving company.
这一切之所以更有意义，是因为这些盒子的起源。故事是这样的：1974年，沃霍尔正要把他的工作室从纽约的一栋大楼搬到另一栋。问题是他出了名的抠门，喜欢买东西，讨厌付钱给别人。所以他没有雇搬家公司。
Warhol told his assistant don't worry about it. He'd just pack everything up himself. But the assistant, fearing that he and the other members of the staff would end up having to do it all themselves, came up with an idea.
沃霍尔告诉他的助手不用担心。他自己把所有东西打包就行。但助手担心他和工作人员最终得自己动手，想出了个主意。
He suggested to Andy that rather than viewing the boring old cardboard packing boxes as just ways to transport his stuff from one place to the next, he should think of them as time capsules. It was exactly the kind of trick you resort to when your kids won't eat their vegetables by making a chore into a game. And it worked. Big time.
他建议安迪不要把那些无聊的旧纸箱仅仅看作搬运东西的工具，而应该把它们视为“时间胶囊”。这正是你为了让孩子吃蔬菜而把杂务变成游戏时会用的伎俩。这奏效了。效果惊人。
Even after the move, Andy kept making the capsules. He kept open cardboard boxes on his desk, in his studio, in his house, filling some up right away, taking years to fill others. He was hooked. He'd found the perfect outlet for his hoarding impulses. Instead of having to throw anything away ever again, he could just stick that thing into a box and call it art.
即使搬家后，安迪也一直在制作胶囊。他在办公桌、工作室、家里都放着敞开的硬纸盒，有些很快就装满了，有些则花了几年才装满。他上瘾了。他为自己的囤积冲动找到了完美的出口。从此再也不用扔掉任何东西了，他只要把东西塞进盒子里，称之为艺术就行了。
We get a lot of confetti and potpourri because the time capsules happened partly in the '80s, and people were fond of mailing invitations with potpourri or confetti.
我们收到了很多五彩纸屑和干花，因为时间胶囊的部分过程发生在80年代，人们喜欢用干花或五彩纸屑寄请柬。
Confetti and glitter just line the streets in the '80s.
五彩纸屑和闪粉在80年代铺满了街道。
Yeah. I feel like once a week, one of us opens something with confetti in it, and we're like oh, crap.
是的。我觉得每周都有一次，我们中有人打开装有纸屑的东西，我们就会说，噢，天哪。
Then you have to go and, like, pick up all the individual pieces of confetti?
然后你必须去把所有的纸屑碎片捡起来？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
You do? Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是的，是的，是的。
Every piece of every object is part of the art and has to be officially catalogued. So glitter gets scooped up and put into a container like a film's party scene being rewound. Plastic bags go into other plastic bags. Cassette tapes go unplayed so as not to damage the physical audiotape.
每一个物体的每一部分都是艺术的一部分，必须正式编目。所以闪粉被扫起来放进容器里，就像电影里的派对场景倒带一样。塑料袋被放进其他塑料袋里。磁带不被播放，以免损坏物理音带。
A sealed deck of cards from Penn and Teller with the secret to a magic trick concealed inside isn't opened so as to preserve the plastic wrapping. The museum's chief archivist, Matt Wrbican, says normally archivists will throw out staples and paper clips. Not here.
一盒密封的佩恩和泰勒纸牌，里面藏着魔术的秘密，没有被打开，为了保持塑料包装完整。博物馆的首席档案管理员马特·维比坎说，通常档案管理员会扔掉订书钉和回形针。但这里不行。
The paper clips get numbered.
回形针也要编号。
Really?
真的吗？
Really.
真的。
Do you guys ever feel like suckers for doing it, for buying into it?
你们有没有觉得因为做这些、因为相信这些而像个傻瓜？
Matt once-- he recently said that this was Andy's joke on the art world. And the three of us were like, that's our job.
马特最近说，这是安迪对艺术界开的玩笑。而我们三个人的反应是：这就是我们的工作。
So this is typical. We have a few boxes that are like this, that just have vitamin bottles that he was taking at the time, just, like, the empty packaging, 20 or 30 of them in here.
所以这很典型。我们有几个盒子是这样的，里面只有他当时吃的维生素瓶子，就是那种空包装，里面有20或30个。
In this room that's so antiseptic, where the procedures are so set and paperclips become museum objects, we're still dealing with a man's stuff. It's very personal. The girls know that Andy's dry cleaner's name was Danielle and that she was always sending him bills, which he ignored. He did the same with the surgeon who saved his life after he was shot, who they found a note from that read "pay up, you blow hard."
在这个如此无菌的房间里，流程如此严谨，回形针变成了博物馆展品，但我们依然在处理一个男人的私人用品。这非常私密。女孩们知道安迪的干洗店老板叫丹妮尔，她总是给他寄账单，他对此视而不见。他对救了他一命的外科医生也一样，他们发现了一张便条，上面写着“付钱吧，你这个吹牛大王”。
But they also know that along with unpaid bills, he would send art donations to charities. They know there were letters from fans asking him to sign an enclosed photo, and the photo will never be there, which means he sent it back to them signed. They know what he looked like without his wig on, that he had a comb over.
但她们也知道，除了未付的账单，他还会给慈善机构捐赠艺术品。她们知道有粉丝写信请他签署随信附上的照片，而照片永远不会出现在那里，这意味着他签完后寄回给他们了。她们知道他摘掉假发后的样子，知道他是个地中海发型。
They know that there's a whole box he made devoted to his mom and how that one felt extra personal because some of her clothing was inside, and that can connect you to a person more than anything else. They found Andy's clothing in the capsules too. They know there are certain things you can't learn about a person just through reading, like the actual size of their waist.
她们知道他专门为他妈妈做了一个盒子，那一个感觉特别私人，因为里面装着她的一些衣服，那能比任何东西都让你与一个人产生连接。她们在胶囊里也发现了安迪的衣服。她们知道有些东西是无法通过阅读来了解一个人的，比如他们腰部的真实尺寸。
None of the girls say they knew much about Warhol before this job. They're young. One of them says, "um, I knew his name." And so watching them feels like watching three really nice people tenderly unpack a stranger's house.
这几个女孩中没有人说她们在这份工作之前对沃霍尔了解很多。她们很年轻。其中一个说，“嗯，我知道他的名字。”所以看着她们就像看着三个非常好的女孩正在温柔地拆开一个陌生人的房子。
And there's more gift wrap.
还有更多的包装纸。
It's cute.
真可爱。
There's a lot of gift wrap.
有很多包装纸。
Do you want to open that?
你想打开那个吗？
Under the gift wrap, the girls discover some photos of Andy taken outside.
在包装纸下，女孩们发现了一些安迪在户外拍摄的照片。
[GASPS].
[喘息]。
Oh, these are--
噢，这些是……
Oh, nice.
噢，真不错。
Oh, neat.
噢，真好。
It's a photo of Andy on a wood pile.
这是一张安迪坐在木头堆上的照片。
The pictures are just casual snapshots. The girls lean in closer, touching shoulders.
这些照片只是随意的快照。女孩们凑得更近，肩膀碰着肩膀。
For Andy from--
致安迪，来自……
John?
约翰？
John, oh. From John Gould?
约翰，噢。来自约翰·古尔德？
Who was John Gould in his life?
约翰·古尔德在他生命中是谁？
He was his boyfriend.
那是他的男朋友。
And-- oh. I'm swooning.
而且……噢。我被电到了。
Are you?
是吗？
Yeah, little bit.
是的，一点点。
Those are actual dreamy sighs you're hearing. It's nice. After all the stuff they've gone through, the exciting stuff, the gross stuff, it's still Andy himself that gets the strongest, most affectionate reaction.
那些是你听到的真实梦幻叹息。真好。在她们经历过的所有事情中，那些令人兴奋的、恶心的东西，最终依然是安迪本人引发了最强烈、最亲切的反应。
Why? Do you like-- are you guys attached to John and Andy together?
为什么？你们……你们对约翰和安迪在一起这件事有感情吗？
I'm more attached to Andy and Jed, I think, to Jed Johnson.
我觉得我更喜欢安迪和杰德，杰德·约翰逊。
I don't have a favorite partner, no. I like finding photos of Warhol just hanging out, not at a party, not at an event. He had this friend Joan Quinn who was out in California. And I'd always just love when she sends stuff.
我不偏爱哪个伴侣。我只是喜欢寻找沃霍尔闲逛的照片，不是在派对上，也不是在活动中。他有一个朋友叫琼·奎因，在加州。她寄东西过来时我总是很高兴。
She sends these great photos of them all just hanging out together. He always looks like he's having fun and relaxed in the photos that she sends. Maybe because it's California and it's laid back. I just like the idea of Andy-- I don't know-- having people around him that care about him.
她寄了一些他们聚在一起闲逛的照片。在她寄来的照片里，他总是看起来很开心、很放松。也许是因为加州生活很悠闲。我只是喜欢安迪——我不知道——身边有关心他的人的想法。
Whatever Warhol intended when he packed these boxes, I think it would have been hard for him to imagine this, that strangers would open them and go through his stuff and be the last people on earth to get to know him this intimately and end up liking him even more than when they started.
无论沃霍尔打包这些盒子时意图如何，我想他都很难想象到这一点：陌生人会打开它们，整理他的东西，成为世界上最后接触他并如此亲密地了解他的人，最后甚至比刚开始时更喜欢他。
Starlee Kine in New York.
斯塔利·凯恩，纽约报道。
[MUSIC - BRAINPOOL, "JUNK"]
[音乐 - BRAINPOOL，《垃圾》]
Act Three, Christmas or Bust. Now this story of a Christmas present and a teenager at Christmas trying to do right by his parents. It's a work of short fiction from Russell Banks.
第三幕，圣诞节还是破产。现在这个故事关于一份圣诞礼物，以及一个试图在圣诞节对父母尽责的青少年。这是一篇出自罗素·班克斯的短篇小说。
I didn't go to jail for it or anything. But I think of the time I got caught shoplifting at the lingerie store up at the Champlain Mall in Plattsburgh as the beginning of my life of crime. It was supposed to be the first Christmas after my mother and stepfather kicked me out of the house when I was still 14 and crashing at my friend Russell's place with the bikers down on Water Street in Au Sable Forks.
我并没有因此坐牢什么的。但我认为我在普拉茨堡尚普兰商场的内衣店因入店行窃被抓的那次，是我犯罪生涯的开始。那应该是我母亲和继父把我赶出家门后的第一个圣诞节，当时我才14岁，寄宿在我的朋友罗素家里，就在奥萨布尔福克斯沃特街那群机车党那里。
They were letting me sleep on this ratty couch they had, because I was dealing weed then and kept them supplied on credit. But mostly when I hung out there, I stayed in Russell's room. The bikers were older than us and were heavier into drugs. I saw one of those guys once rub a line of coke straight into his eye, which kind of grossed me out. Plus they drank a lot.
他们让我睡在那张破烂的沙发上，因为那时候我在卖大麻，而且一直赊账供应给他们。但大部分时间我待在那里时，都待在罗素的房间里。那群机车党比我们大，药瘾更重。有一次我看见其中一个人直接把一行可卡因擦进眼睛里，那真的让我觉得恶心。况且他们喝了很多酒。
Russell was 16 and worked days part time at The Video Den. At nights we used to ride up to the mall in his Camaro so I could deal a little weed to the other kids. And we would hang out until the stores closed and hit on the girls. But mostly nothing was happening, so we'd sit around on the benches and watch all these cheesy couples doing their Christmas shopping, which was pretty depressing.
罗素16岁，在“视频小窝”做兼职。晚上我们经常开着他的卡马罗跑车去商场，这样我就可以给其他孩子卖点大麻。我们会待到商店关门，然后去搭讪女孩。但大多数时候什么都没发生，所以我们就坐在长椅上，看着那些俗气的夫妻们在购物，这真的很令人沮丧。
At Christmas the malls are filled with people who feel rotten because they don't have enough money, so they fight a lot. The carols and blinking lights and the guys in Santa suits are supposed to make you forget your troubles. But it's the opposite. At least for me it was, which was one of the reasons I liked to get high before we went there.
在圣诞节，商场里挤满了因为没钱而感到难受的人，所以他们经常吵架。那些颂歌、闪烁的灯光和穿着圣诞老人套装的家伙本该让你忘掉烦恼。但事实恰恰相反。至少对我来说是这样，这也是我们去那儿之前我喜欢先嗑点药的原因之一。
This one night, about 10 days before Christmas, I didn't have any weed. And I was thinking about my mother and stepfather, how it would be the first time they would be alone. And I wondered what they'd do on Christmas Eve.
有天晚上，圣诞节前10天左右，我没有大麻。我在想我的母亲和继父，这将是他们第一次单独在一起。我很好奇他们在圣诞夜会做什么。
What they usually did was get smashed on this eggnog and bourbon mixture my mother said was her mother's secret recipe and watch TV specials. Around 11:00 when the news came on, we'd open the presents we got for each other, hug, and say thanks. And then they'd go into their room and pass out. And I'd smoke a joint in the bathroom and watch MTV with Willy, the cat, until I fell asleep.
他们通常的做法是喝得烂醉，喝我妈说的那种她妈妈秘制的蛋酒和波本威士忌混合饮料，然后看电视特别节目。大约11点新闻播出时，我们会拆开给彼此准备的礼物，拥抱，说声谢谢。然后他们会回房间昏睡过去。我就会躲在浴室里抽一支大麻，和猫咪威利一起看MTV，直到我睡着。
It was OK but not exactly ideal. But we had a tree and lights in the windows and all. And last year was cool because I got this excellent suede shearling jacket from my mom. And my stepfather gave me a Timex watch so I could start coming home on time, he said.
这还行，但并不是很理想。但我们有圣诞树，窗户上有彩灯。而且去年很酷，因为我从我妈那儿得到了一件很棒的麂皮羊毛夹克。我继父给了我一块天美时手表，说这样我就可以开始准时回家了。
I got her one of those long silk Indian scarves that she seemed to like a lot. And for him I got a pair of lined driving gloves. Everybody was happy in spite of the eggnog.
我送给她一条那种长长的丝绸印度围巾，她好像很喜欢。至于他，我送了他一副带衬里的驾驶手套。尽管有蛋酒，每个人都很开心。
But a lot happened since then. For one thing, the main thing, I guess, I got kicked out of the house for stealing and pawning my mother's coin collection that she had inherited from her mother and that she was someday going to pass on to me. But it also had to do with my getting a mohawk and my ears pierced and screwing up in school.
但那之后发生了太多事。其中一件，我觉得最主要的一件，是我被赶出了家门，因为我偷窃并典当了我妈从她妈妈那儿继承的硬币收藏，那是她有朝一日打算传给我的。但也与我留了莫霍克发型、打了耳洞、在学校捣乱有关。
And even though they never caught me at it, they knew I was heavy into weed, which was why I had stolen the coins in the first place. When I left, it was sort of by mutual agreement, I guess. They would have let me come back if I wanted but only if I could be a different person than I was, which was not only impossible but unfair because I didn't know how to keep myself from getting into trouble anymore.
尽管他们从没抓到我，但他们知道我严重依赖大麻，这也是我当初偷硬币的原因。当我离开时，这算是一种双方达成的共识吧。如果我愿意，他们会让我回来，但前提是我必须变成一个与之前完全不同的人，这不仅是不可能的，而且是不公平的，因为我根本不知道如何避免自己陷入麻烦。
I must have crossed the line back when I was a little kid, like five or six, after my real father took off and my stepfather moved in and married my mom. My stepfather was OK. But I know he didn't mind at all when he and mom found out I stole the coins and they got to boot me out of the house. I knew my mother wanted me to come home. But no way I was going back as long as it didn't make the both of them happy to see me.
我一定是在小时候，五六岁的时候就越界了，那是我的生父跑了，继父搬进来娶了我妈之后。继父其实还好。但我知道当他和妈妈发现我偷了硬币，并且有机会把我赶出家门时，他一点也不介意。我知道我妈妈希望我回家。但只要看着我不能让他们两个都开心，我是绝不会回去的。
So I started imagining this scene. I get Russell to drop me off at my mom's and stepfather's house, which is really only a mobile home except it's got a foundation under it and a deck in back like a regular house. All my stuff, including my trademark dirt bike, is in Russell's car. And we unload and set it on the sidewalk.
所以我开始构思这一幕：我让罗素把我送到我妈和继父的房子，那实际上只是个移动房屋，只是它下面有地基，后面有个像普通房子那样的露台。我所有的东西，包括我的招牌越野摩托车，都在罗素的车里。我们卸下东西，放在人行道上。
But also, I've got this huge bag of presents for my mom and my stepfather, truly excellent items like a toaster oven and a Crock-Pot and maybe some jewels and a fancy nightgown for mom. And for my stepfather, a Polaroid camera and a portable sander and a Polo ski sweater. Then Russell takes off and I'm alone.
但同时，我带着一大包送给我妈和继父的礼物，绝对是好东西，比如烤面包机、慢炖锅，也许还有珠宝和送给妈妈的一件精致睡袍。送给继父的是宝丽来相机、便携式砂轮机和一件Polo牌滑雪衫。然后罗素开车离开，我一个人待着。
The house is dark except for the string of lights around the front door and the electric candles in the windows. And I could see the Christmas tree lights blinking through the curtain in the living room where I know they're watching The Cosby Show or something. It's Christmas Eve. It's snowing a little.
房子里一片漆黑，只有前门周围的一串灯和窗户上的电蜡烛亮着。透过客厅的窗帘，我能看到圣诞树的灯光在闪烁，我知道他们正在那儿看《考斯比一家》之类的节目。平安夜到了。正在下着小雪。
They're really sad because I'm not with them, and they don't know how to let me come home without acting like what I did to them doesn't matter, stealing the coin collection, smoking grass, getting a mohawk and all, and living with Russell and the bikers, and not going to school anymore, which they probably know about by now, and dealing weed for Hector, the Hispanic guy at the Limbo, which they don't know about. Although, I wonder what they think I've been living on all these months, charity? Also, they don't know that so far I haven't gotten a tattoo, even though Russell has two very cool tattoos on his arms and is always after me to get one.
他们真的很伤心，因为我没跟他们在一起，他们不知道如何在不掩盖我对他们所做之事的情况下让我回家，比如偷走硬币收藏、抽大麻、留莫霍克发型、和罗素及那些机车党住在一起，还有不再上学——这些他们可能现在都知道了——以及为在“灵薄狱”酒吧的那个西班牙裔家伙赫克托卖大麻，这些他们还不知道。虽然，我很好奇他们以为这几个月我是靠什么生活的，靠慈善？另外，他们不知道的是，到目前为止我还没纹身，尽管罗素双臂上有两个非常酷的纹身，总是催我也去纹一个。
Anyhow, in this scene, I go up to the door and knock. And when my mom comes out, I say Merry Christmas, mom, just sort of flat and normal like that, and hold out the bag with all the presents wrapped in this incredible shiny paper with bows and everything. She starts to cry, and my stepfather comes to the door to see what's the matter. I say the same to him. Merry Christmas, Ron, which is what I call him, Ron. And I show him the bag of presents, too.
总之，在这一幕里，我走到门口敲门。当妈妈出来时，我说，“妈，圣诞快乐，”就像那样，平淡而自然，并递出那个包裹着令人难以置信的闪亮纸张、带着蝴蝶结的礼物袋。她开始哭，继父出来看发生了什么事。我也对他说了一样的话，“罗恩，圣诞快乐，”罗恩，这就是我叫他的名字，罗恩。我也向他展示了礼物袋。
My mom opens the door and takes the bag from me and passes it to Ron and gives me a big hug. Ron shakes my hand and says, come on in, son. We go into the living room, and I distribute the presents to them. And all is forgiven.
我妈打开门，接过袋子，递给罗恩，给了我一个大大的拥抱。罗恩握了握我的手说，“进来吧，孩子。”我们走进客厅，我把礼物分给他们。一切都被原谅了。
They don't have any presents for me, which embarrasses them, naturally, and they apologize. But I don't care. All I care is that they really like what I got them. And they do.
他们没有任何给我的礼物，这自然让他们感到尴尬，他们向我道歉。但我不在乎。我只在乎他们是否真的喜欢我给他们挑的礼物。他们确实喜欢。
Later, we're drinking eggnog and watching TV. And Ron looks out the window and sees my bike and all my clothes and things out on the sidewalk with the snow coming down. And he says to me, son, why don't you bring your stuff inside?
后来，我们在喝蛋酒看电视。罗恩往窗外看，看到我的摩托车和我所有的衣服东西都放在雪地里的人行道上。他说，“孩子，你为什么不把你的东西搬进屋里来？”
When I got busted for shoplifting, it was in this fancy lingerie store called Victoria's Secret. And I was already out of the store with a green silky nightgown stashed in my jacket pocket. A black security guard, a dude I actually knew and had once sold some grass to, put the arm on me and turned me around and took me into an office in the back where the manager of the store and the head security guy were.
当我因为入店行窃被抓时，是在一家叫“维多利亚的秘密”的高档内衣店。那时我已经带着一件绿色的丝绸睡袍藏在夹克口袋里走出了商店。一名黑人保安，一个我认识的人，我曾经卖过一些大麻给他，他抓住了我，把我转过身，带进了后面的办公室，那里有商店经理和保安队长。
And after they hassled me for a while, I told them my mom's name and telephone number. The black guy who busted me had to go back on patrol. And when he left the office, I looked real hard at him. But he didn't care. He knew I couldn't pin him for anything without pinning myself worse.
在他们对我进行了一番盘问后，我报了我妈的名字和电话号码。抓我的那个黑人不得不回去巡逻。当他离开办公室时，我死死地盯着他。但他不在乎。他知道我没法举报他，因为那样会让我自己陷得更深。
And then, of course, a half hour later, here they come, my mother and my stepfather, her looking frightened and upset and him just burned, but neither of them talking to me, only to the store manager and the head of security. While they talked, they made me sit by myself in a storeroom next to the office where I stared at the no smoking sign and kept wishing I could get high. And a few minutes later, my mother came out wringing her hands with her face all red from crying.
然后，当然，半小时后，他们来了，我的母亲和继父，她看起来惊恐而不安，他则是一脸怒火，但他们两人都不跟我说话，只和店经理及保安头子说话。在他们交谈时，他们让我独自坐在办公室旁边的储藏室里，盯着禁止吸烟的标志，心里一直希望能嗑点药。几分钟后，我妈走出来，双手紧紧地绞在一起，脸上因为哭泣而通红。
They want to arrest you, she said. And Ron agrees with them. He thinks it would be good for you, she said. But I'm trying to explain that we've all had a lot of troubles on the home front this year, and you're just reacting to that. I'm trying to get you off, do you understand? Do you? I said, yeah, I understand.
“他们想逮捕你，”她说。“罗恩也同意。他觉得这对你有好处，”她说。“但我正在尝试向他们解释，我们家今年遇到了很多麻烦，你只是对此做出的反应。我在努力让你脱罪，你明白吗？明白吗？”我说，“是的，我明白。”
Then she said, if you'll go in there and say you're sorry and say that you'll come home with us and stay away from the mall, I think they'll forget about the shoplifting. And Ron will go along. This could be your last chance, she said. Come on.
然后她说，“如果你愿意进去道歉，说你会跟我们回家，远离商场，我想他们会忘记入店行窃的事。罗恩也会配合。这是你最后的机会了，”她说，“来吧。”
And she took me by the arm and led me back into the office where my stepfather was joking with the store manager who was a bald, middle aged guy, and the head security guy who had a gun strapped to his waist. The three of them were buddies now, and they looked at me and my mom like we were insects. Go ahead, my mom said to me, and she pushed me forward a step. Tell them what you told me.
她挽着我的胳膊把我领回了办公室，那里我继父正和店经理开玩笑，经理是个秃顶的中年男人，旁边还有那个腰间别着枪的保安队长。他们三个现在是哥们了，看着我和我妈就像看着某种昆虫。“去吧，”我妈对我催促道，并向前推了我一把，“告诉他们你对我说的那些。”
I hadn't told her anything. But I knew what she wanted me to say. I felt weird, like I was in a movie and could say anything I wanted and it wouldn't make any difference in the real world.
我根本没对她说过什么。但我知道她想让我说什么。我感觉很怪，就像身处电影里，可以随意说任何话，而在现实世界里却不会产生任何改变。
They were all staring at me, waiting. So I looked down at my feet and said, My friend was going to lend me $50, but he didn't get paid in time. See, there you go, my stepfather said. The kid doesn't know right from wrong.
他们全都盯着我，等着。于是我低下头看着自己的脚说，“我的朋友本来要借给我50美元，但他没能及时拿到报酬。”“你看，就是这样，”继父说，“这孩子是非不分。”
What the hell did you want with a woman's nightgown? he laughed, holding up the gown with his thumb and one finger like it was porno or something, like he thought I was going to wear it myself. No way I was going to answer him. So I just stood there.
“你到底想要女人的睡袍干什么？”他大笑着，用拇指和食指拎起睡袍，好像那是什么色情制品之类的东西，好像他以为是我自己要穿似的。我绝不会回答他的。所以我只是站在那里。
And after a minute or two with no one saying anything, my mother took my arm and led me back out to the storeroom. Listen, mister, she said, really upset. I'm going back in there one more time. And, remember, I'm the one putting myself on the line for you. If I get them to let you go, you have to promise me that you'll come home with us and that things will be different. Do I have your word on that?
过了两分钟没人说话，我妈挽着我的胳膊把我领回了储藏室。“听着，先生，”她说，非常沮丧，“我要再进去最后一次。而且，记住，是我在为你争取。如果我能让他们放过你，你必须答应我，你会跟我们回家，事情会变得不同。你能答应我吗？”
Yeah, I said. And she left and went into the office. I could hear them arguing through the wall, my mother's voice high pitched and pleading, my stepfather's voice low and grumbling, and once in a while some comments from the store manager or the security cop.
“会的，”我说。她离开了，走进了办公室。我能隔着墙听到他们的争论，我母亲尖锐而恳求的声音，继父低沉而粗暴的声音，偶尔还有店经理或保安的评论。
It seemed like hours, but it was probably only a few minutes before my mother came back out all sad smiles now. And she gave me a big hug and kissed me on the cheeks. She held both my hands in hers and looked up at me and said, It's all right. They're going to let you go.
感觉过了几个小时，其实可能只有几分钟，我母亲就带着悲伤的笑容出来了。她给了我一个大大的拥抱，亲了亲我的脸颊。她握着我的双手，抬头看着我说，“没关系。他们打算放过你。”
Ron finally came over to my side on this. He's going to meet us out front by the Sears entrance with the car. My goodness, she said, smiling. You're getting so tall, honey. It was true. I was taller than she was now.
罗恩最终站在我这边。他打算在西尔斯百货入口处开车接我们。“天哪，”她笑着说，“你长得真高了，亲爱的。”这是真的。我现在确实比她高了。
When we walked out into the mall, I saw Russell sitting on a bench over by the fountain goofing with a kid I didn't know and a couple of girls from Plattsburgh High who were smoking cigarettes and pretending that the guys weren't there. Listen mom, I said. All my stuff's over at Russell's place. I'll go by there with him and bring it over. You and Ron go ahead without me.
当我们走进商场时，我看到罗素正坐在喷泉旁的长椅上，和一个我不认识的小子，还有几个来自普拉茨堡高中的女孩瞎混，女孩们抽着烟，假装没看见那些男生。“听着，妈，”我说，“我所有的东西都在罗素那儿。我会跟他一起去那儿把东西拿过来。你和罗恩先走吧。”
She seemed a little confused. What? Why can't we just stop off there with you and get it now?
她看起来有点困惑，“什么？为什么我们不能直接跟你一起去顺便拿回来？”
No, no, I said. The place is locked. I got to get it with Russell. I don't have a key. Besides, I owe him $20 for the rent. I can't get my stuff until I pay him. Can you give me $20, mom?
“不，不，”我说，“那个地方锁着。我得和罗素一起去拿。我没有钥匙。再说，我还欠他20美元房租。没给钱之前我拿不到东西。你能给我20美元吗，妈？”
I was already thinking about getting high with him and the girls he was talking to and riding around Plattsburgh in his Camaro. No, she said. No, of course I can't give you any money.
我已经开始想着跟他和那些女孩一起嗑药，开着他的卡马罗跑车在普拉茨堡转悠。“不，”她说，“不，我当然不能给你钱。”
I don't understand. Don't you know what just happened in there? Don't you know what I just went through?
“我不明白。你不知道刚才发生了什么吗？你不知道我刚刚经历了什么吗？”
Listen, mom. Just give me the money. I need the money.
“听着，妈。就把钱给我。我需要钱。”
What are you saying?
“你在说什么？”
Give me the money.
“给我钱。”
She looked at me in a strange way, like she didn't recognize me but almost did. Then she reached into her purse and pulled out a $20 and passed it over.
她用一种奇怪的眼神看着我，好像她不认识我，但又几乎认得。然后她伸手进钱包，掏出一张20美元递了过来。
Thanks, I said. And I gave her a kiss on the cheek. I'll be back later after I get my stuff from Russell's.
“谢谢，”我说。我在她脸颊上亲了一下。“拿完罗素那儿的东西我会回来的。”
She seemed shocked and put her hand to her mouth and took a few short steps away from me, then turned and disappeared into the crowd of shoppers. And as I crossed over towards Russell and the other kids, I remember saying to myself, now I'm a criminal. Now I'm a real criminal.
她看起来很震惊，用手捂住嘴，向后退了几小步，然后转身消失在购物人群中。当我朝罗素和其他孩子走过去时，我记得对自己说：现在我是个罪犯了。现在我是一个真正的罪犯了。
So do you know what you're getting your parents for Christmas?
那么，你知道给父母买什么圣诞礼物了吗？
I'm getting my father some new clothes and some cologne. And I'm getting my mother some jewelry, expensive jewelry.
我给爸爸买了一些新衣服和古龙水。给妈妈买了一些珠宝，昂贵的珠宝。
Expensive jewelry? How expensive?
昂贵的珠宝？有多昂贵？
Like, around $200, $500.
大概200到500美元吧。
Oh, my god. That's so nice.
噢，天哪。那真是太好了。
Yeah.
是的。
This 16-year-old was going to pay for the necklace for her mom with the money that she was earning at the Orange Julius Dairy Queen at the mall, which is where I talked to her at Arundel Mills in Maryland. She started there just three and a half weeks before Christmas. And she said that she'd pretty much be spending nearly everything she earned, about $100 a week after taxes, plus her birthday money, to afford this gift for her mom, who works at a nail salon.
这个16岁的女孩要用她在商场里的奥兰治·朱利叶斯冰雪皇后打工赚的钱给妈妈买那条项链，我就是在马里兰州的阿伦德尔米尔斯采访她的。她圣诞节前三个半星期才开始在那里工作。她说她几乎要花掉赚的所有钱——税后每周大约100美元，加上生日礼金——来负担这份给妈妈的礼物，她妈妈在美甲店工作。
Have you ever bought her anything this expensive?
你给过她这么贵的东西吗？
No.
没有。
Have you ever bought anyone anything this expensive?
你给过任何人这么贵的东西吗？
No. This is like my first time I bought something really expensive.
没有。这是我第一次买这么昂贵的东西。
What made you want to do that for her?
是什么让你想为她这样做？
I mean, she's like the world to me, you know? She's always been there, thick and thin. She does so much for me.
我是说，她就像我的全部，你知道吗？她一直都在，无论顺境还是逆境。她为我做了太多。
But your dad is getting kind of short shrift compared to your mom it seems like.
但你爸爸跟你妈妈比起来，似乎收到的重视要少得多。
Yeah. It's just my father hasn't been-- like, he's a father. But he's just, like, he's just not part of the family like my mother is. She's, like, always here supporting us and stuff like that. He's always off somewhere.
是的。只是我爸爸并没有……他是父亲。但他只是——他不像妈妈那样是家庭的一部分。她一直在这里支持我们之类的。他总是跑去别的地方。
So you're closer to her.
所以你跟她更亲近。
Yeah.
是的。
What do you think she's going to say?
你觉得她会说什么？
I think she's going to be more surprised. So, yeah, my mother, she loves all the presents I give her, even if it's, like, homemade. She appreciates all the things I give her.
我想她会更惊喜吧。所以，是的，我妈妈喜欢我送给她的所有礼物，即使是手工制作的。她珍惜我给她的每一件东西。
Yeah, of course, she does.
是的，当然，她会的。
Yeah. There's not a lot of pressure, because she loves anything.
是的。没有太大的压力，因为她喜欢一切。
[MUSIC - BAD RELIGION, "ANGELS WE HAVE HEARD ON HIGH"]
[音乐 - 坏宗教乐队，《听啊，天使报佳音》]
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producers, Julie Snyder and Ben Calhoun, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Jonathan Goldstein, who you heard in the first act, is the host of the radio show Wiretap , which is heard on the CBC in Canada and on many public radio stations in this country. It is also a free and great podcast.
好了，我们今天的节目是由高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德和本·卡尔霍恩制作的，参与人员还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、莎拉·凯尼格、三木·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。你在第一幕中听到的乔纳森·戈德斯坦是广播节目《窃听》的主持人，该节目在加拿大的加拿大广播公司和美国的许多公共广播电台播出。它也是一个很棒的免费播客。
Russell Banks, whose story was Act Three, is the author of several books. His most recent is a short story collection, A Permanent Member of The Family. Production help today from Dana Chivvis.
罗素·班克斯，他的故事是第三幕，是几本书的作者。他最近的作品是一个短篇小说集，《家庭的长期成员》。今天由达娜·奇维斯协助制作。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安·马西奥韦茨负责我们的网站。
Research help today from Michelle Harrison. Music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
今天由米歇尔·哈里森协助研究。音乐由达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder Torey Malatia. Over Thanksgiving-- maybe you heard this-- he was arrested in Las Vegas. It was some incident in a casino. I finally got him to explain.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。感恩节期间——也许你听说了——他在拉斯维加斯被捕了。那是赌场里发生的一起事件。我终于让他解释清楚了。
I had these two pieces of wood. I chopped them up into little squares. They weren't really good squares. And then I painted little dots on them and made them into dice.
我有两块木头，把它们砍成小方块。做得不太工整。然后我在上面点了些点，把它们做成了骰子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - BAD RELIGION, "ANGELS WE HAVE HEARD ON HIGH"]
[音乐 - 坏宗教乐队，《听啊，天使报佳音》]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。